وقع ما عرف بالاتفاق الايطالي في الخرطوم
يوم الخميس من ديسمبر الجاري وكانت
الاطراف التي وقعت عليه تامل ان يكون
بدايه الحل لانسداد السياسي الذي يمر به
السودان شمل الاتفاق اكثر من مستوى فنصت
بنوده على ابعاد الجيش عن اي عمل سياسي
ودمج قوات الدعم السريع بالقوات المسلحه
ومن اي تشكيل اي ميليشيا عسكريه او ما
يشابهها يدخل السودان بموجب الاتفاق فتره
الانتقاليه لعامين تبدا من تعيين رئيس
الوزراء تختارهما تطلق على نفسها قوه
الثوره وعليه ستكون السلطه الانتقاليه
مكونه من مجلس تشريعي ومستوى سيادي ومجلسا
للوزراء خلال الفتره الانتقاليه ستناقش
صياغه دستور للبلاد ثم تنظم عمليه
انتخابيه شامله في نهايه الفتره
الانتقاليه تم الاتفاق على تاجيل مناقشه
بعض البنود وهي العداله الانتقاليه
والاصلاح الامني عسكري واتفاق جوبا للسلام
وتفكيك نظام الرئيس السابق عمر البشير
الاطراف الموقعه على الاتفاق الايطاري مع
المجلس السيادي ابرزها حزب الامه القومي
والمؤتمر السوداني والتجمع لاتحادي
والمؤتمر الشعبي وانصار السنه اما ابرز
المقاطعين الاتفاق فهم الكتله الديمقراطيه
والاتحادي الاصل والتيار الاسلامي العريض
والحزب الشيوعي ولجان المقاومه بالخرطوم
ولهؤلاء المقاطعين اسباب منها رفض التفاوض
والشراكه مع الجيش كما وصف بعض الرافدين
الالتفاق بانه ثنائي واقصائي وادى الى
انشقاقات داخليه